talking about like fonts and having to
choose fonts and just like being thrown
into a world that you just don't
understand sometimes that yeah you never
knew that you know there was this much
thought into it like i remember like
recently uh this is like going off on a
tangent but i remember recently i've
just like
had like a binge not really a binge but
just like had my recommended taken over
by these really weird keyboard asmr
videos
i don't know i don't know if you guys
know what i'm talking about i think i've
seen a couple i don't know
because because uh because how uh how i
how i basically discovered it was just
this random keyboard video right and i
was just like why is there a keyboard
video of just someone typing on my
timeline so i click on it just just uh
because i think that i think the video
title was just listen to the sound of
this keyboard or something right right
and it was just like him like oh or like
him or her like just pressing the keys
right and just and the title was just
listen to the space bar right and it's
pressing the keys right
and then you go to the spacebar
and it just sounded like a space bar i
was like it's just a space bar and then
i go to the comment section to be like
what what's what's going on and all of
the comments were just like i was i was
having a nice time until you press the
space bar and then i vomited and it and
it was just like the vomit emote or
something like that and i was just i've
never been put into a world that i just
did not understand well i mean like i i
kind of felt that when uh i think it was
connor right who got like i think one of
your fans made like a custom keyboard
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but then they
also you know with the custom keyboard
which looked sick as [ __ ] there was also
this like other smaller keyboard where
you could test out oh that was going oh
that was gone okay it was like it was
like a smaller keyboard where you could
test out all the different types of keys
yeah yeah and like hammers and i'm just
like
what's the difference
like i touched all of them and i was
like
half of these sound the
i think i think they are someone who's
like using the one of the expensive
keyboards because i don't think it was
given to me i would never have gone out
my way and paid that much yeah yeah yeah
to me it was all the same yeah now i get
it because i use it right before i i
didn't understand what the difference
was right but i really like the
smoothness and like the subtle clicks
yeah now that i've watched it it's a
very slight click but it's really nice
yeah now that i'm like like 20 keyboard
videos down i kind of get it there's
like a nice there's like
it's it's like the thunk sound right
there's it's the thunk sound where it's
do you though or have you just been
conditioned maybe i've just been
conditioned i feel like i'm i'm one of
you cherry mx brown switches can suck my
dick there you go uh welcome keyboard
enthusiasts
i'm like the cherry switches i can
actually tell they [ __ ] suck now i
used to have it what's that what the
cell like why why why it sounds like
like a car crashing every time you
[ __ ] press it it's so goddamn loud
and clicky oh you mean like the clicky
ones super super clicky okay [ __ ] those
ones [ __ ] they bought like i had one in
my old office in the uk and since i went
back to the uk it's probably like cherry
brown mx switches they're like the
cheapest thing i think it's like the
cherry blue oh
yeah yeah yeah
the the gatrion ones the gate is like
gatron's where is that i've got
it's like oh it's [ __ ] good yeah it's
[ __ ] good dude yeah i really like the
gate on like milk yellow i believe it's
it's literally called milky or something
milk because it it like it just has this
like
nice little thunk to it and it's nice
it's like asmr right it's just it's so
smooth and it's like it's milky it's
like this just it just sounds like one
piece arc
the guy the guy the guy
he's talking about he told me like what
lube he used and i was like i don't need
to know what you jacked off with but i
appreciate it
yeah so so to explain like i'm also
getting a custom keyboard made because a
fan message me yeah um but like dude i
mean like
i i did pay for the yeah this thing yeah
yeah so he was like oh do you want to
get a keyboard made for you and it's
being in the process of being made and i
was just like yeah sure
thinking that he was just going you know
he was just going to send something that
he recommended and he was like no we're
going to do the entire process right
like what kind of what kind of keyboard
you want you want like a 100 you want a
75 percent do you want to like a 50 i
was just like what you are saying
numbers right now it's a keyboard what
are you talking about full 100 keyboard
keyboard and i want every part there
yeah why would i only need 75 of the
keyboard
i don't like the number pad and all that
[ __ ] on the side i don't i used to not
care but now that i have a keyboard that
doesn't have a number pad i understand
why it's unnecessary to have it because
i realized i realized until it was gone
i never [ __ ] used it i know i know
some people will like go ham on it and
like
i'm out here i'm totally fine with the
top thing yeah so i just want to save
room
i use number pads okay yeah um mostly
because when you're human huh i do it's
just
mostly it's it's useful because it's all
the numbers are just close together
yeah i recognize it's the superior way
to handle numbers it is it is but
with the amount of like two-factor
authentication i have yeah you know what
i mean like like i'm constantly using it
it's not that it is it is it is this
although i definitely had a moment where
like you know i was like you know i
should probably start using the number
pad yeah my old keyboard because it's
there but then i had a moment where i
was just like damn it's so hard to use
them with my left hand
and i was just like doing this and i'm
like oh maybe i should just take my hand
off the mouse and just do this
i was like oh why is it why is it not on
the left side it'd be so much easier but
then i was like oh i could just let go
of the mouse and perhaps just do this i
thought you were implying that your
right hand was like when you're digging
oh my god you're like jacking off for
you like oh let me put in my credit card
while i'm like jacking up like playing
wrong
yeah i mean if you're like an accountant
or something right you'd be pressing
numbers all day yeah it makes sense like
i should be used to that layout as well
because it's like you know every
calculator is that layout right so it's
like why is it so hard for me to use
when it's on a keyboard yeah even though
on a calculator it's like basically
second nature yeah like i i i mean
the reason i like the number pad is
because buying a lot of things online
you've got to enter your credit card
number a lot
um log into your bank account details
how much should you buy yeah it is like
actually beneficial to have that real
estate taken up
um like i don't know what like i just
have enough i feel like i use it a lot
because sometimes i need to log into my
bank and you know you when is when
you're entering purely just numbers it's
not like a password that's when the
number pad is useful and like when
you're like entering the numbers on the
line marginally though marginally useful
oh missed optimization i thought i
thought you'd be one of me man
you'd be one of me you're trying to
optimize two things at once how fast can
you type stuff in but also the the space
in your desk you know right right i got
a lot of like [ __ ] on my desk cause you
know they got like god knows how many i
got like two audio interfaces i got a
bunch of other cables
i will admit the aesthetic looks better
without them
the aesthetic looks better also
travels easier you know trying to put a
number you can put a key like a uh
what are they called the 75 half
keyboards yeah 75 yeah 75 keyboard you
can put that in the backpack you can't
put a full one in your bag that's too
big why would you
sometimes you're going somewhere maybe
you're going to a lan event or something
not that i do anymore but
what was the last time you went to a lan
event university yeah
i think like it was like high school but
also like you know what if you don't
like the the keyboard on your laptop i
get it because sometimes the laptop
keyboards suck and you want to bring one
with you if you're going to be like
having a remote setup right packing a
full-size keyboard in the backpack it's
paying the attention i've never little
things i've never been that desperate
i've never been like every time i've
realized
you don't realize how
how good having like things smaller and
taking up less space is yeah but like
it's not it's not like my laptop
keyboard isn't so [ __ ] detrimental to
me where i'm like i gotta pack another
keyboard
that you'd rather pack a keyboard
without a number path than just use the
laptop keyboard that makes less sense
that is the opposite of optimizing yeah
you're taking
i don't want to play games on the laptop
uh keyboard screen controller could
bring a control but some games don't use
controller well then don't play those
games okay well but you're probably
playing these games joe you're just
being pedentic now for no reason just
just play a game that you can use the
controls i know for a fact i'm not alone
i've seen people do this so many times
people don't want to use the [ __ ]
keyboard on the laptop
i've never gotten to the point where
okay i have a remote setup right a
remote setup is not like your permanent
setup right yeah if i really really
really need a keyboard i just buy like a
[ __ ] five dollar keyboard or
something like that you know like it's
cause i use the laptop one yeah no like
i i like if if i've really really wanted
like a remote like a remote setup it's
all about the ergonomics you know like
using a laptop keyboard for hours like
actually [ __ ] hurts your wrists using
a keyboard for hours hurts my wrist no
no no no that's why
that's why i'm trying to use controller
for everything like a nice keyboard you
know good ergonomics doesn't doesn't
hurt your wrist you bring up the wrist
as well yeah yeah
you got the rest too electrons don't
have rest i just you know my laptop it's
amazing right but i i have to like it's
just there's no support or anything i'm
just putting i'll just bring the [ __ ]
rest then i just feel like down on like
the uh the [ __ ] track pad and [ __ ]
it's coming away it's kind of annoying
yeah it just doesn't work it doesn't
work i just feel like the inside like
someone in the office understands this
point i just think like the whole point
of a laptop is to be portable no it is
like and and like but at that point you
might as well keep monitoring the
keyboard fits in the back it's portable
you know what i mean like
you can't bring a beat the reason why
laptops portables because it's not a
giant [ __ ] case not because the
keyboard is like on it that's like one
of the reasons if i'm whipping it out in
the cafe yeah i'm going to use the
laptop keyboard right i'm replying you
know it's not a big deal if i'm
streaming or gaming i want a [ __ ]
keyboard but in
howie like if you're at the point where
you're
bringing a portable set up right like in
which
tell tell them tell me this tell me this
hypothetical situation where you need to
set up an entire stream setup because
i'll tell you it's not just a [ __ ]
laptop you need to bring your if you're
bringing your entire [ __ ] stream set
up how much are you bringing like what
are you when i went to the uk last time
i brought it with me you know you just
bring because if i want to film stuff
anyway i bring a camera anyway the
camera has two uses i can film other
stuff
lights no i don't bring lights you don't
need lights you know you can figure out
lighting it's not a big issue right
it's just having a good camera a good
mic and then if you want to play games
or [ __ ] you bring a keyboard and a mouse
you're not going to [ __ ] use the uh
the trackpad right no you're not going
to use training
yeah a trackpad is like totally
different than the mouse right right but
i mean
if you have a 75 keyboard it's not that
big
but then like another thing is like are
you still gaming on the laptop or do you
have like a monitor that you're using as
well uh on the laptop's fine the screen
i have on my laptop's is pretty good
well that's not very ergonomic isn't it
of course it is it's like
this
desks over there my my other keyboards
here this one's there it's further away
because since i have more room now
because the keyboard's not attached to
the thing so i can place the screen
where i want it to so it is taking all
this is it me or does this just sound
very pretentious no this is not this is
this is if i want to like do it
if you want to go portability why not go
for a 50 keyboard then or fifty percent
or twenty five thousand dollars
what is the fifty percent how can you
remove less
that there is less
you would be surprised you would be
surprised what are you removing
smaller keys well no i won't be able to
press
why don't you just invent a keyboard
which is just the spacebar and the arrow
keys
i don't know who who uses the arrow keys
yeah well you if you're playing games on
the keyboard
okay or wasd put the number
like it is really not that hard to bring
a 75 percent keyboard your bag on your
suitcase
it's like it's like
it's like half of a pizza box you know
what i mean it's like not even it's tiny
it doesn't take up room and your clothes
are the padding it's it's this isn't
hard why is it so crazy to you it's like
i'm bringing a [ __ ] like pet dog in
my bag why is this so unbelievable
because because it's just like
at that point at that point where you
are not at that point when you're
bringing a streaming setup a number pad
is not that much more surface area okay
but what i'm saying is like that's just
unnecessary like in general like in any
keyboard setup just put the function
keyboard in your like checking well
technically if you get a 50 keyboard
you're removing unnecessary keys right
you know you know that's that that's
that's the entire thing no it's not like
75 percent is like
it's called a preference connor it's
called a preference okay
i would i would argue right the reason
why 75 is no different from the 100
because you don't lose anything right
then you have you just have numbers
twice i don't need numbers twice i see
numbers once
this is not why is this like you're
saying like
removing the second numpad is not equal
to being like get rid of half of the
alphabet this is not the [ __ ] same at
all why i can't believe this is an
argument you're making it just uh
imagine in a hotel you're stuck for a
week yeah yeah if you wanted you want
the tv screen to be your second monitor
yeah leave your laptop there and you can
sit at your bed with your wireless 75
percent yeah every every hotel every
airbnb i do not pack a keyboard wherever
i go no that's fine but why are you
clowning on me this is not like a clown
thing to do this isn't just sounds
incredibly pretentious and tedious how
is it pretentious what because i want to
let me just get my 75.
because everyone works differently yeah
like i can't go to a starbucks and work
like that's not i i'd be like why is it
so pretentious going if you go to a
starbucks to type you know what i mean
like work from home
like i don't see how this is pretentious
i'm losing my mind no no no it's the way
that you're framing it as like this is
the superior way to type this is the
only keyboard that works number pads
number pads irrelevant unnecessary this
is necessary
all i'm saying is you have your
preference i i like using the number pad
because i use it enough functionally for
me to be able to justify that it is a
convenience for me all right
how did this get to me being clowned on
for bringing keyboards
how how did this get this trash taste
baby
that's not that's not the reason you
were clowning on me god the reason you
were trying to clown on me is because i
brought keyboard places it's funny
that's like
it's
it's it's it's a lot okay it's it's it's
a lot i'm just like there is
i understand it's a preference you know
i understand it is a preference that you
want to bring your keyboard have you
never thought like when you're like
trying to play games you're like why are
my hands so [ __ ] close to the screen
no i've not i've i've because here's the
thing like i don't really i'm not a
gamer
right right so why don't you just say
that in the first place instead of
pretending like you were
i never pretended like
because because i told you what i'm
using the keyboard for and then you're
like no no that doesn't exist
i also have a portable streaming setup
but i just don't need i don't need to
keep it i don't i don't think to myself
i cannot i am i i am a karthus main in
league of legends i have a one percent
keyboard it's the r key
[Music]
like if i need to game while i'm out and
about i just bring a [ __ ] controller
and just play games that use a
controller yeah but like what if
someone's like oh dude uh you've
arranged a game with someone the game
doesn't have controller then i'll use
the keyboard i'm not going to [ __ ]
have a hissy fit over and be like
where's my 75 percent i wouldn't have a
hissy fix i would have brought it
[ __ ] with me so there wouldn't have
been yeah but even what if you didn't i
always bring it with me and now it's not
happening this is the waste of space
it's not a waste of space it's it's thin
it's small how is a keyboard a waste of
space what
i don't know
i'm just [ __ ] arguing
i just feel like you guys are just being
pedentic
yeah because it's funny
i mean i i feel like i feel like the
argument is are you gay more are you not
a gamer you know
you are 100 gamers
you know i want to write a lot of emails
and stuff to the point of like if i'm if
i'm doing a lot of work you know i'm
typing for a few hours like yeah i'm
trying to bring my own i just it's
because like for me it's like i i will
be so much less efficient using the
laptop ones i just won't be comfortable
um
no
i mean i'm i'm
okay that's that is just that is just
purely just you looking for any like i
don't know like no
because i'm the scripter here i i
actually write more than you connor
he actually writes more than you keep
saying like because when you work one
way everyone must work the same way and
you've re you're like like
so if someone writes a lot they're the
ones that we should ask like okay tell
me about keyboard ergonomics and how
well no that's not hard
are you saying that you can't write as
efficiently if you don't have the right
keyboard and everything how did you
function how did you function before
like
the 75 keyboards got popularized you
know because it was lighting with i'm
not doing wingdings i'm not writing with
a [ __ ] number pad gone
what you want this is nothing to do with
the 75 percent now what are you talking
about but now we're talking about the
difference between laptop and keyboards
yeah i i am i'm just i'm just like if so
you know your laptop doesn't have a
number pad right yeah i know
like
i'm not saying that i'm not saying that
it doesn't matter
i just bring like a portable number no
no no no no no i don't like it
that's just the number
listen how you work is like totally up
to you right if you if you are a person
who gets really agitated by a certain
way and that's just like that bugs you
yeah i think that's just that's up to
you could you just knuckle down
sometimes and get on with it yeah you
can but i mean at the end of the day
it's if you're doing something creative
and and it's something that you're your
own boss with you're probably gonna work
as much as you want yeah and sometimes
comfort is a factor in that and for me
that's what i need yeah but you're
gaming you know if i am working there as
well it's the same thing i just don't
want to use it right right right
anyway
i don't even know how he got on i don't
i don't even know man i don't even know
that was the most long-winded dumbass
argument we've ever had
i just felt like i explained a very
valid point and then i got i got jumped
on it
i don't know uh i don't know what you
were explaining exactly i don't i don't
even know
i don't know who you are but it is
totally a reasonable behavior to to not
want to use that okay okay because
because like maybe it's because i don't
have a castle and keyboard yet but like
i don't
fully understand i don't take my main
keyboard i take some like fifty dollar
one that's my side
i just need one that's further away and
that i can set up to be more like wait
so you don't even take your your
good
optimized custom keyboard not like the
super expensive one no i just take like
one so you have several keyboards yeah
well i learned my lesson because when my
keyboard broke one time i couldn't do
any work or couldn't stream or anything
right and i you know i was [ __ ] and i
was like well this seems dumb so now i
just bought i have a spare keyboard
yeah because like it's a good idea yeah
if your entire job
revolves around
doing like being able to use this one
device yeah you should probably have
backups of everything that could
possibly break that's fair enough but i
don't think i've ever broken a keyboard
before
keyboard keyboards breaks all the time
you know maybe you've had a key that was
acting up that was pissing you off or
yeah maybe the you know yeah yeah it
happens all the time yeah keyboards are
like [ __ ] frail things yeah yeah
because to me like houses break all the
time i got like three backup mouses yeah
cause like maybe like this this comes
down to the conversation like me and
tech like even though i'm an engineer
i'm i don't like i just need a job to be
done you know what i mean i don't really
care about aesthetics or like right
stuff too much i just like
aesthetics i don't care about that you
don't well
it's just about it's about like just
preference of like how i like it to work
yeah you know yeah because like for
example like headphones for example i
literally don't like i i
my preference with headphones is to buy
like the cheapest headphones i can
possibly right well i'm the opposite
with headphones yeah yeah yeah because i
i know people are like really really
really
in here right in here yeah you don't you
don't use headphones right here like
clamshell headphones you mean those are
headphones right
yeah i don't yeah i don't i prefer to
use headphones every other time
i don't like yeah to me like headphones
i don't know why um i think it might be
because i have like jaw problems or
something like if i wear headphones for
too long it just like really starts to
put pressure on my jaw and stuff but
like yeah with with earphones and like
not this is going above the tech but
like there are certain things like
earphones sunglasses where i try to buy
the cheapest possible because i've gone
through too many or you know like just
sometimes you buy like you i remember
buying like well like at the end of
every day you're like crack
all right next one
no yeah because like sometimes i
misplace them or something but
especially with sunglasses right so it's
so easy to misplace sunglasses
especially because you wear them out and
sometimes you just you don't always have
your case on you or sometimes you you
know you take you don't have a bag or
anything you take them off you like clip
them on your shirt and they just fall
off sometimes like i've i've had that
happen too many times and with earphones
sometimes you just get sometimes you
replace misplaced them or you like
forget that they're in your jean pockets
or something um
so so you the headphones kind of make
you uncomfortable because they like put
pressure on your head yeah yeah yeah
it's the same thing for me and the
keyboard and the wrist though it just
hurts my wrist if i if i if i have to
use that flat thing for ages right
because your wrist is like why why are
we doing this also i i'm like paranoid
about getting any wrist injuries or
carpal tunnel yeah i you know i want to
get
i'm very cautious about like
wrist injuries so i i want the most
ergonomic set up why don't you get like
those like uh wrist guard things then
i've seen a couple of strangers yeah
yeah i mean that's that's they know they
normally have that on when it's too late
and they've already like done oh no i
know some people who have it on like to
actually just prevent it i mean if you
have a good setup you shouldn't need
that right but you know even people with
good setups can sometimes you know game
a little too hard but like headphones
like for me it's like i can't have the
in-ear ones because any every single
in-ear headphones for some reason wants
to like excavate your ear yeah and get
really in there yeah yeah and then that
hurts the [ __ ] out of my ears
so i can't use those it's probably
because you don't have like the right
size buds right yeah i have one that
comes with a bunch of replaceable ones
but even then like airpods unironically
are the ones that i like the most
because they don't really go in your ear
much yeah they kind of like sit on top
of it that's what i like the most but i
don't use apples i don't have them
and that's why i use it like the
overreal ones also the sounds way nicer
i only use the over ear ones if it's
like in the winter because it also like
keeps my head warm but like in the
summer here especially i'm just like
nope headphones go away i should always
use them
yeah i do like i've seen you like
walking in like the japanese summer with
headphones on i'm like yeah that looks
bad that is dedication
listening that's your comfort i mean you
your headphones have taken a [ __ ]
beating it's like it's like i remember
seeing it like falling apart it's like
falling apart man like holy [ __ ] buy
some new headphones dude yeah well it's
because it's because it's because i'm
waiting for the right now i'm using the
sony wx
um 1003 the worst naming system of all
time yeah yeah the [ __ ] is going on sort
of string of numbers and letters and
then like the the next one the fours i i
isn't really a significant upgrade yeah
and i'm hoping the fives when they ever
come out which i don't even know if they
will i'm like a decent upgrade i'm kind
of in that weird spot where it's like
they're they're like broken and they're
not working properly yeah but but like
because they're like you know 300
headphones yeah i want them to last like
five years yeah of course so
if i buy the the fours now and then the
fives come out and they're like the most
best upgrades and you can hear god
through them yeah i'm gonna be really
pissed off that i bought these fours
yeah and i just didn't wait a few months
after but i don't know what i don't even
know if it's coming out i don't even
know they haven't even announced or
anything so i'm just waiting kind of
hoping you're waiting for something to
do it works yes
one side is completely broken so it
keeps falling out yeah just don't take
that [ __ ]
i thought about it